I was scuba diving in the course of
tiomat island with a bunch of my new
fishy friends after the dive I decided
to take in the sunset by the beach and
that's where I found something washed up
ashore it was a bright yellow Pelican
case which said Dave the diver and then
I realized this is Dave the diver
exclusive press kit I unboxed it and
found so many goodies we got a nice
postcard a brochure about the game
[Music]
a nice tote bag
a pin featuring David diver
fridge magnets featuring bancho Dave and
Cobra and finally a figurine of Dave the
diver stand included it's one of my
favorite unboxings and I can't wait to
bring this back to my aquatic friends
[Music]
foreign